whether it's at my restaurants or at
home I think food should always stand up
and be noticed it doesn't matter if a
dish is light and delicate or full-on
and Gutsy the flavors should be distinct
and clear and that means always getting
the maximum taste from your ingredients
today it's all about vibrant muscular
food so fasten your seatbelt for my
ultimate breakfast lunch and dinner
packed with big and bold flavors first
up a Punchy breakfast of burgers and
Fontina stuffed croissants the flavor
there is incredible for lunch a spicy
Mexican soup be adventurous but beware
serve with quick tortilla chips and a
peek at the Gaia dip Maggie for dinner
I'll be setting the world to write with
my eldest Megan
I'm so annoyed when we make one of our
favorite dishes crispy roast duck with
pancakes and black bean dipping sauce
Cena's is your favorite now you can make
it followed by a spiced banana tartatan
wow
these are my ultimate recipes for a day
versing with a big and bold breakfast
lunch and dinner starting with a
breakfast that can't fail to wake you up
hello guys and Fontina stuffed
croissants okay big and bold when I was
living in France I stayed there for
three years once twice a week I treated
myself to the most amazing
bold breakfast and they started off with
these Beauties here mergys cheap but
incredibly tasty
start off with a nice hot pan my gaze in
it's a very spicy sausage doesn't need
any help doesn't need any chili just a
touch of salt and pepper
you can smell the spice they're starting
to release all that wonderful oil that
flavor in there
add a couple of cloves I'll finally
sliced garlic
spread the garlic across the pan so it
instantly changes color takes on this
nice dark Rich golden color
now take a look with the heat out for
the parsley
the stalks of soft herbs like parsley
and coriander can be used to impart
flavor during cooking but the leaves
should always be added just before
serving to give maximum color and
fragrance
and then finish that off with my capers
amazing
now take your quest on
they're literally 24 hours old so
they're crispy on the outside and just
slice off
the lid
this recipe is a great way to use up any
leftover croissants from the day before
I used to cringe when I saw the French
Cooks throw away croissants I used to
cry thinking oh my God
any idea what he's throwing away in
terms of flavor whatever you do do not
wipe out that pan dunk your croissants
mopping up all that amazing flavor and
caramelizing the inside
for that beautiful don't forget the lids
and then get your thumbs and go inside
the croissant
all I want to do now is create a little
pocket
and just manipulate the croissant now
this is where it gets exciting mix up
the Capers the garlic the sausages look
at the color
all that wonderful delicious flavored
oil now some cheese but not just any
cheese Fontina cheese is like the number
one cheese for grilling and because it's
a very rich cheese you shave it thinner
than you would a white truffle but it
gives a really nice saltiness and a
light Smoky flavor
salt
place these big boys on the tray
literally 30 seconds
on the grill
here we go
crisp
packed full of Flavor now top them
and that for me it's almost like being
back in Paris
[Music]
except this time
I don't have to share them with the
French
My ultimate big and bold breakfast
mergers and Fontina stuff croissants a
great way to start the day
[Music]
never be scared of trying new flavors in
your cooking
a few key ingredients can make all the
difference here's a closer look at some
I'll be using later
[Music]
peppercorns may be small but whatever
the color in terms of flavor they're one
of the heavyweights on the kitchen
foreign
s are fruits from the same flowering
Vine
it's the stage which they are harvested
and how they are processed that
determines the unique colors of taste
today I'll be using the fiery black and
perfume Pink types to add a big bold
punch to my pudding
for dinner I'll be cooking Ducks hugely
popular Chinese cuisine this bird may be
less meaty than a chicken but it's
intense rich flavor means the meat goes
a long long way
waffle farmed duck meat is packed with
protein vitamins and essential nutrients
and I'm gonna slow roast one my dinner
dish a crispy roast duck or pancakes
chillies are a fabulous ingredient and
one of my absolute favorites is the
Chipotle
Chipotles begin life as a green jalapeno
pepper the process of drying and smoking
lends an intense Smoky flavor to balance
their spicy Heat
[Music]
dried Chipotle can be brought as a paste
powder or whole which is how we use them
for my big bold lunch
Chili's come in all shapes and sizes and
heat and are used throughout the world
but if there's one Cuisine has really
turned cooking them into an art form
it's Mexican they're experts at building
layer upon layer flavored with delicious
chilies and spices so for my ultimate
big and bold lunch spicy Mexican soup
it's hearty delicious robust but served
with some tortillas and a wonderful
salsa it's almost like a complete meal
in one starting with some finely chopped
red onions for my soup let's get some
heat going early these are chipotle so
they're Smoky Rich they don't come with
any warning signal and these are
seriously hot so be adventurous but
beware
nice teaspoon of toasted cumin oregano
dried
now it's not frying off spices the heat
you'll see the chilies start swelling up
delicious garlic
be quite generous on the oil because
that helps to blow out the chili right
now those onions and garlic are on fire
we're going to balance the sort of heat
from the Chipotle with sugar
turn up the heat and really starved
caramelizing that sugar and the chili
gives off the most amazing aroma
next fry up a tablespoon of tomato puree
add a can of chopped tomatoes
cook kidney beans and vegetable or
chicken stock to cover there's something
quite exciting about big and bold
flavors because in the restaurants you
have to be somewhat controlled you can't
go crazy
so cooking these kind of dishes at home
gives me that kind of release chilies
particularly when they're dried continue
to swell and release their heat as
they're cooked so the longer you cook
your dish the hotter it will be
it's not as powerful it needs to be yet
and every five six seven eight minutes
actually gonna get stronger hotter and
more delicious
bring it up to the ball and cook that
out for 15 minutes
whilst I allow the chili heat to infuse
I'm going to crack on with quick crunchy
tortilla chips and a fabulously fresh
and spicy tomato salsa no New Mexico has
pico de gallo
[Music]
start by finely dicing three ripe
tomatoes
one or two to see the fresh jalapeno
peppers
and half a red onion
then chop a good handful of fresh
coriander
choose from two limes salt and pepper
and a drizzle of extra virgin olive oil
[Music]
for the tortilla chips rub a little
olive oil onto six large bought wheat
wraps
sprinkle with smoked paprika and gently
massage it
cut each wrap into triangles and spread
them onto a baking tray
bake for three to four minutes in a
seasoned oven 180 degrees until golden
brown and lead to cool
to complete my Mexican lunch I need to
finish my deliciously fragrant spicy
soup
[Music]
the spices there it is absolutely spot
on
now for the cooling down process the
Mexicans are brilliant at building layer
upon layer of flavor with delicious
chilies and spices but they're also
experts at tempering their dishes with
cooling ingredients like avocado sour
cream and cheese that's why you can take
that amount of chili you'll have a spoon
of richness spice all of a sudden
avocados almost like a little fire
blanket over those chillies
to further counter the chilly heat
Mexicans use a rich Tangy crumbly cheese
but I'm sprinkling on Lancashire which
is a Great British substitute
and last but not least cooling fresh
coriander one delicious spicy Mexican
soup serve that with your tortilla chips
and your pico de gallo salsa
a phenomenal blend of textures and
layers and spice and creaminess big bold
and delicious one of the secrets to
making fantastic food at home is
learning to be confident when you're
using strong flavors all dishes need to
be balanced but don't be afraid of using
herbs and spices to make your cooking
vibrant and exciting here's my ultimate
big and bold dinner a meal that demands
to be taken notice of
in the kitchen is my eldest daughter
Megan
[Music]
with the addy kick on the black bean
dipping sauce
Megan
gonna help with the duck Danny your
favorite yes
yes now how's your boyfriend
right I'm going come on that woke you up
didn't it
so what do you love most about duck
the dipping sauce
and let's get the duck in the oven first
a little bit of salt in there please
then some pepper thank you
some spring onion garlic and ginger now
why do you think we pour that in there
to season it and flavor
how comes you put them in whole like
that not
it's going inside we're not using it for
a sauce or anything so it's just going
to make it really nice well they
[Music]
so what happens as the duck roasts on
the outside it creates this really nice
perfume Aroma inside
tuck that in there to get it spicy rub
all that Chinese five spice yeah over
almost like you're massaging
good
let's make sure you get it all in even
the little wings here underneath there
just like I used to do to you with a
bath
I know those days are long gone I know I
know I know
that is seriously spicy with the duck
there's generally quite a lot of fat
there yeah so we're gonna put it on this
little bench
okay and that
goes there
by slowly roasting it okay it's gonna
get nice and crisp on the outside all
that fat is going to render inside the
breast so therefore it's going to get
all nice and juicy yeah right ducks in
three and a half hours at 160 degrees
Celsius
your favorite part you said was the
dipping sauce why is it your favorite
part I think it really adds to the dark
it makes it really tasty seen as it's
your favorite now you can make it I'm
gonna do nothing okay daddy's gonna put
your feet up so first off the garlic as
one good girl wash your fingers please
always do good
nice
oh you're fast huh what's your fingers I
am
what's your fingers slide slow down
please
14.
that's enough right little teaspoon of
olive oil a few years time we'll be
teaching how to drive as well as cook
how exciting is that you and I in a car
scary
okay garlic in
crispy duck is traditionally served with
hoisin sauce but my brood love the
additional big bold punch of black beans
it's nice Megan and I add soy sauce and
lastly for that classic Chinese sweet
and sour element brown rice vinegar and
honey
are you happy with the flavor I'm really
happy
you can taste everything in there
dipping sauce done ducks in the oven
let's start the dessert the most amazing
Tata tan
they are pink peppercorns
they're really good they don't taste
anything my black peppercorn quite sweet
aren't they they're really sweet very
fruity the pink peppercorns give it the
sweetness the black peppercorns give the
heat now
what is that baby
vanilla this is one of the easiest
desserts in the world to make but one of
the most delicious it's a sort of take
on the classic apple or pear to tan but
when you caramelize as bananas with the
peppercorns and the vanilla I bet that
tastes amazing oh my goodness incredible
okay I made the caramel start off with
the coal pen first
and you just press that butter in there
how come do you do it like that and not
let it just melt naturally because I
want the butter to stay cold because I'm
gonna stick the bananas in there okay
and then we'll make the caramel and
caramelize the bananas at the same time
so in goes those vanilla vanilla seeds
pods in there as well okay peppercorn's
done yeah and done good girl sprinkle
them over that butter just naturally
naturally yeah
nice and they're not just very carefully
sprinkle sugar
over that
you're doing them all the same size
roughly the same size
wedge it into the butter well you know
what I want the bananas really
caramelized
stuck them between
if you cram them in like this okay they
will stop them moving around
[Music]
nothing's moving nothing is okay so all
wedged in there let's move the
peppercorns on top of the banana so
you've got that flavor
in the caramel and the top and the
bottom right
a pastry
puff pastry is difficult and time
consuming to make so I always buy ready
made when I'm at home
to get the best flavor and texture go
for the all butter type and keep your
pastry cold before using it
and this is where it gets really
exciting you get your fingers you just
pinch the end so you thin the end if you
can do that for me very carefully you
have to be quick because the heat of
your fingers can melt the pastry how
comes you do it Doug because we get it
nice and thin so we can clip it
underneath
now take a spoon and what we do is lift
up that banana and tuck it underneath
see looks like a parcel like a parcel
and see the thin bits of pastry yeah how
easy it is to get it underneath yeah and
that's why you thin them out you do it
so quickly or because I have to be quick
otherwise the paste will melt
notice how we're not using anything
sharp so we're not would that cut the
pastry if you that's right
see how locked down that is
gas on
we'll start caramelizing that those
three little holes are so important if
we didn't put a hole in the patient and
it will cause a lot of steam so the
pastry never Cooks it just goes really
soggy okay so really important the
camera's live now we're working the
camel give a little Shake how can you
see the caramel through the pastry look
what happens when it tilts oh yeah see
all comes running down see yeah I see
now that pastry okay is like clinging on
to the bananas and so when we turn it
upside down we've got this glove full of
these caramelized bananas
look at that wow
[Music]
look
it's your birthday soon 15. I just
worked out
on my 50th you're 18.
perfect we should do a joint party yeah
love it 12-2-4 for the old ones 12 lunch
time till four for the old one so they
can go to sleep Megan we'll go on later
perfect
this is what I get excited now look at
the color of that caramel so tilt the
pan again see how dark it is now yeah
it's gotten a lot darker now didn't take
long didn't take long at all that's
nearly ready for the other one but
before I put that in I'll get the duck
out wow
how's the doctor
crispy wow and delicious
how crisp it is it's really crispy
that's what happens when it slow Cooks
so 20 minutes for the duck to rest and
20 minutes in the oven 190 to 200
degrees for our banana tart attack
time to knock up a quick Hoisin and
cucumber salad to put in our crispy duck
pancakes
for the dressing combine hoisin sauce
rice wine vinegar
soy sauce
a dash of sesame oil
and to give it that thingy Asian punch
some freshly grated brewed Ginger
for the salad trim and cut spring onions
into very fine matchsticks
peel a whole cucumber into long thin
ribbons
by shredding a couple of baby gem
lettuces
season and toss this fresh crunchy salad
in a sweet yummy Hoisin dressing
a combination that never fails to get
the kids eating their greens wow look at
that
so see now where that pastry is
caramelizing caramel so dark and just a
little tip
gas back on and that will release it
because if you tip it and it's still
sticking then some of your bananas
will stick yeah so now see when it
starts spinning around like that it's
moving around and here we are the Moment
of Truth when you know your daddy
is the best chef in the world ready
wow
the vanilla
how delicious
isn't that really good as well
done crispy doing sauce can you give a
salad ready so if you take them and your
dipping sauce thank you I'll take the
duck don't drop it promise
oh
okay
this is amazing
my ultimate big and bold dinner of
crispy roast duck with pancakes with a
Hoisin dress salad and some extra oaf
from Megan's favorite black bean dipping
sauce
[Music]
nice
Holly I think he's a bit more duck in
there
honestly it's like a black burrito funny
dad
and for a big and bold pudding delicious
spiced banana tart to town
Jack's gonna be so up can I have a
little bit
I think we might have to save him some
swimming makes him very hungry let's
save him a wishbone in the duck that's
me
there are loads of more great home
cooking recipes on my app cook with me
you can find it in the App Store good
luck
[Music]
great home cooking is built around
classic dishes everyone's got their
favorites from super simple breakfast to
traditional Sunday roast the secret is
not to let your classes go stale make
sure you keep your cooking exciting by
tweaking and adapting it here are some
of my ultimate Classics dishes we
couldn't do without in our house but
given delicious new twists first I turn
the quintessentially British breakfast
on bald egg and Soldiers on its head
next my eclectic wholesome take on a
classic plan with lunch ham or cheese or
Stilton is hard to dictate which one's
the best I'm gonna put all three in my
eldest Megan helps me rust up a new spin
on a classic roast beef with Yorkshire
pudding they're amazing it's incredible
there nice big chunks lovely and we get
stuck in to make an unconventional eaten
mess
oh okay yeah got meringue in my eyes
[Music]
there's something quite nostalgic about
a boiled egg it's something that's never
lost it's magically sliced that top off
and dunked that Soldier into the yolk
can't mess with a deliciously runny yolk
but this is what I'd like to dunk in it
an anchovy Soldier anchovies into pessim
water no salt naturally yeah anchovies
are very salty so just a touch of pepper
grind them
it's a really nice smooth paste the
smell of that is almost like being on
the seaside now get your soft butter
and just put half the butter in first 50
50 is the way 50 anchovy 50 butter that
way you've got that real nice salty
creaminess mix that up
that's absolutely delicious trust me
finishing that anchovy butter on a slice
of grilled fish I'm in heaven the bread
this is a Sourdough delicious very
crusty take four nice slices
now get that pan nice and hot
a couple of tablespoons of that anchovy
oil into the pan and then get your bread
and lightly fry each side
smell and that anchovy oil is incredible
take that out
now bring your water up to the boil The
Secret of softly boiling an egg is to
place them into the water gently on a
spoon in and just tilt so they don't hit
the bottom nice and Light
up to the ball count to five turn the
gas down is it four and a half minutes
is it five minutes for soft boiled egg
I've cooked thousands of them and every
time
it's four and a half minutes whilst
that's boiling
get your bread
spread that on there that is incredible
chopped parsley brings that kind of
freshness
goes brilliantly well with the anchovies
hear that crunch
on
and cyber I can't resist
oh my God
right
gas off one
Beauty in
two
I feel like a five-year-old again
this is that moment when you open the
vault and that little magic inside is
all yours
there's a great Twist on a great classic
wow
[Music]
perfectly soft boiled eggs we're dressed
up anchovy butter soldiers
who would have thought that egg and
soldiers could be that delicious
[Music]
classic recipes tend to be made with
ingredients we all know very well
but however familiar they are it always
pays to hunt out the very best here are
a few tips when you're buying the key
ingredients for today's lunch and dinner
recipes
[Music]
than the cheese that's been produced
here since the 12th century cheddar
engine made in the caves of the cheddar
gorge in the west country it's still Far
and Away the UK's cheesy of choice in
Britain Jenna ourselves all the other
cheeses
good quality cheddar has an Amber yellow
Hue and it's firm but not greasy or hard
[Music]
River beef is the classic granddaddy of
all roasting joints it's generous
marbling of fat keeps his flavor some
meat moist and succulent as a rule of
thumb one limb should generously feed
two mouths to feed my ramble for dinner
tonight I'll be needing a three rib
joints
no roast beef dinner is complete without
the nose tingling the light that is
a member of the mustard family this
route is related to Wasabi broccoli and
cabbage but looks more like a knobbly
parsnip for dinner tonight I'm gonna
break with tradition and give my
Yorkshire PUD batter a delicious
horseradish kick
[Music]
and this becomes a classic because it's
delicious and somehow strikes a chord
with us it just works sometimes these
dishes can become tired but a clever
twist helps make them fresh again
you can't get more classic than a
centuries-old midday meal of bread
cheese and beer reinvented a mask if I
perv as a plan was lunch I'm now giving
it my 21st century take
like plumbers with the most amazing but
super simple beer baked bread hearty and
full of flavor
for a really quick and easy bread dough
sieve a mix of wholemeal and
self-raising white flour with a good
pinch of salt
is really important to breath it's the
first thing I do once I've cracked it
and smelt you want to smell that salt
baked throughout beer in about 250 ml of
beer
the reason why this recipe works so well
is that the beer it's got that yeast so
naturally it's going to work beautifully
give that a really good mix I'm looking
for the mix to be quite wet if the dough
becomes too firm then it's going to cook
dry in the center
just as it starts to fall through the
Whisk that is perfect
beautiful this mix will work really well
at one large loaf but I want to make my
plan ones a little bit more special
small tens give it that kind of intimacy
and I quite like having my own little
loaf
the molds are really nice
lining with butter make sure you butter
the top
now a tablespoon of flour dust inside
the mold
that will stop your mixture sticking
tap out any excess
three quarters fill your little molds
we're going to allow it to sort of Rise
just so it comes above the mold and
forms this really nice miniature loaf
onto the tray centimeter apart into the
oven 25 to 30 minutes at 180.
[Applause]
something quite nice about the smell of
home baked bread in the kitchen
delicious
no plan was it's complete without
pickled onions Red Onion is a lot
sweeter less harsh than a white onion
the early days of
plowmans you've got those ghastly sharp
pickled onions that make you almost cry
when you're crunching them on the
lightly pickle my red onion
just push your fingers through so you
get these nice sort of onion rings
little touch of salt a little sprinkle
the sugar and then a couple of clothes
in there that gives it a really nice
sort of perfume that sort of makes the
pickling slightly more mellow
rid of my vinegar now if you haven't got
red wine vinegar white wine vinegar it's
just as good but red matches the Red
Onion so it goes hand in glove a couple
tablespoons of vinegar
let's give that a really good
mix
speed up the pickling process use a way
to put pressure on the onions
as the weight presses down on the onions
the clove the salt the sugar the vinegar
work the magic and it comes out with a
really nice light fragrant pickle
to my 21st century plowmans I'm creating
an all-in-one salad and bringing the
traditional elements together with a
Punchy dressing
[Music]
a tablespoon of honey
a touch of salt and pepper
and finish off with white wine vinegar
and olive oil
[Music]
now generally it's sort of three parts
oil to one part vinegar that's the sort
of General base
[Music]
you don't really think of a vinaigrette
with a plan ones but this is a really
nice sort of modern approach to plowmans
to my clam and salad I'm using a mixture
of robust and crunchy romaine lettuce
and Punchy Watercress if I was making a
Watercress soup I'd use the stalks but
the stalks are a little bit better so I
just grabbed them like that pinch them
and then twist
[Music]
very peppery very hot but so juicy
Watercress in
your celery chop it nice and finely
it's the one thing that every leaves is
that stick of celery so scatter it
amongst the salad
a bit of own fun color from some sliced
radishes and sweetness from a thinly
sliced Apple
whilst you're busy throwing your Plum
and salad together do not forget about
your beer bread
before it comes out I want to glaze the
top a little touch of milk that'll put a
really nice finish to the bread back in
for the last five minutes
now for the magic and the plowmans
generally you'd see it as a ham or
cheddar or Stilton almonds it's hard to
dictate which one's the best
so for the ultimate plowmans I'm adding
all three
for your cheddar
peel some nice shards of that delicious
creamy cheddar let's get them dancing on
top
the dressing drizzle ran in circles and
then finally
our delicious lightly pickled onions
getting a good squeeze
and not just dot the onions around
bread it's ready
it's got that nice yeasty smell warm
crusty and delicious
there you go that is my classic modern
version of a traditional stunning
plowmans
wow
my delicious
updated from the 21st century
I think a fantastic Sunday roast is the
Cornerstone of home cooking it's what
the rest of the week's meals are built
around and I absolutely love it but that
doesn't mean it can't be improved
to make the most out of my roast my main
things
complete with Tangy horseradish
Yorkshire puddings
but first i'm enlisting the help of my
eldest 15 year old Megan to reinvent one
of my all-time favorite classic desserts
right he's a mess what's the one thing
you love about he's a mess I love the
meringues now this is a eaten Mess With
a Twist what's the twist in it compared
to the normal one we're gonna freeze it
so it's almost like a sort of eaten mess
bomb wow now I'd like you to whisk the
cream please
half the strawberries are going to go
through the mix and half the
strawberries are going to be turned into
a strawberries in first a little
dusting of icing sugar into the pan and
now the icing sugar will withdraw the
sweetness from the strawberries and
start caramelizing so let me show you a
nice quick way of whisking secret
whisking is like 10 seconds on
10 seconds off that way your arms don't
get tired
now I'm going to take the cream to a
three-quarter stage what is a
three-quarter mix so we leave some sort
of texture in the cream and that's what
we call
three-quarter Whip and you've got a nice
soft Peak
they're caramelized I'm gonna put a
little touch of water in there that'll
help break down the sugar
and turn that into a really nice
strawberry liquid
now to get it really nice and fine I'm
going to blend it on
some Blitz
off okay that's fine I don't want you to
use the back of the spoon and push that
through the sieve okay now that way if
you don't get those seeds smells so good
I love the smell nice this is the
exciting part
oh mag s right now the meringue with
your fingers just crush and Flake the
meringue into the cream how big should I
crush it though
there nice big chunks okay lovely
oh you okay you've got meringue in my
eyes damn to make this dessert even
easier I often cheat by using good
quality Shop Port meringues and it'll
taste that's just cream and bread
um
wow it's a little tasty okay
strawberries in next a couple spoons of
the cooling
now look at that now
prepare the mold to transform the
traditional eaten mess into a frozen
bomb form a triple layer of climb film
adding water to the Bowl will help the
slim film stick as I pour that in I want
you to spread it down okay the bottom
and push it down can you hear that
crunch
now
fold the trim film over put that in the
freezer please Megan please in the
freezer she goes
dessert done now for our main course
with a Twist that is the rib eye we've
had that in the fridge not wrapped so
it's sort of almost air dries and it
intensifies the flavor gross so much
quicker and there's less water in the
beef
for me the only downside to perfect
roast dinner is the fight about washes
up afterwards so Meg and I are going to
avoid that by cooking everything in one
roasting tin starting with the spinach
and mushroom stuffing
filled with a salt and pepper please
good girl
some of your left shoulder so left
shoulder thank you then with the garlic
and the mushrooms let's toss the pan you
push down and pull back down and push
back off you go take your time
push it down and flip that good that's
it push down
nice yeah that was lovely and again
nice oh I'm gonna drop it well done well
done well done Brian's I'm gonna sort of
make a little well a little touch a
butter in the middle
now I'm going to start putting the
spinach in the middle please
so you can push that down spinach is
cold so you're not going to burn
yourself
be confident in the pan toss it and
you'll see it wilting and disintegrating
away wow who would have thought that
spinach could fit in this pan because
it's a very delicate Leaf it sort of
cooks so quickly put this all on your
board now
and then I just want you to go and give
that
a nice chop then when you're confident
with one hand
we need to pick up the other knife the
other hand
chop it nicely
cheers
now outside and come in gently
good regroup
and take your time yes
right
I love that smell what is that lemon
thyme lemon time that's right so you get
your little thyme stalks and you cool
down you sort of strip lemon thyme in
now Target a little taste
brilliant with the beef fantastic with
chicken and fish roughly chop the target
a nice sprinkling of fresh breadcrumbs
so the bread crumbs almost sort of bring
the stuffing together
next we're gonna get an egg yolk now
with the beef this is the exciting part
slice with the bone and then come inside
and go two thirds of the way down
hold that open for that salt
and pepper and then look we pack our
stuffing in there this is amazing it's
incredible now just gently hold that
there like that
okay yeah I'll see you tomorrow what
time string around the rib we'll keep it
all together during roasting not too
tight if we tie it too tightly what
happens if something will come out
that's fine
that's ready for roasting but we're
gonna protect it and sit it on a trivet
so the trivet basically is almost like a
sort of little little bed a little bed
that's right
if you want to enjoy these delicious
roast vegetables at their best make sure
you remove them from the hot oven after
35 minutes and reheat before serving
with your beef
now a little mix for the top a couple of
teaspoons of mustard powder in salt a
couple tablespoons of olive oil mix that
in
I'm gonna pull my mustard powder over
the beef so this forms a really nice
glaze
my one pot roast dinner goes into a hot
oven 15 minutes at 230 degrees then down
to 170 degrees for another two hours yes
very delicious Twist on traditional
Yorkshire puds of the lace mine with
freshwater fish
start with plain white flour in a bowl
and crack in the eggs adding only half
of your milk at this stage makes it
salad and if like me you like your
puddings a little lighter and crispier
add a dribble of cold water and add salt
to season when you're happy your batter
is lump free whisking
whiskey and great horseradish
[Music]
we can leave the batter to rest while we
get the meat from the oven that is
beautiful and this is where you really
need to let it rest how long just those
rested for um I like to rest the meat
for at least 20 minutes
just the right amount of time for us to
whack up the oven and to get our
Yorkshire puddings in I love using the
rich dripping but best of all it's a
healthier option to get the fluffiest
Yorkshires your tray and fat must be
piping hot for best results take your
jug of batter to the oven and pour the
mixture in there it takes just 15
minutes for our Yorkshire puds to pop
themselves up and turn a delicious
golden brown with the Yorkshire puddings
on the way and the beef rested we can
finish off the Eaton mess bomb run the
bowl under the hot water
twist and pull nice wow look at that
beauty
it's amazing sit there
on
to your plate now the Finishing Touch is
a drizzle of the remaining strawberry
Coulee I'm just gonna pour this over an
amazing flavor
and some grated mint chocolate and that
is a nice Twist on a classic eaten mess
a delicious eaten mess bomb beautiful
let's go baby
please
it's not around as much
sorted and the beef is ready to serve up
lift that up place that onto the board
parsnips parents you can see why we kept
them in halves they've got all that
flavor one beautiful Big Slice
put Daddy
one for Maggie and then on the side the
stuffing the stuffing stuff in a bit
that's the best to die for now fantastic
Yorkshire they're amazing aren't they
beautiful that's for you my darling
on that one there's so many
beautiful roast beef
with a Twist wow
[Music]
these are my ultimate Classics with a
Twist juicy River beef with horseradish
spiked Yorkshire puts
and scrummy Eaton mess bomb top of
strawberry Cooling and mint chocolate
with the young kids out of friends his
dad's just me Tyler and Megan to get
stuck in that is a rib eye Fit For A
King oh wow it's cooked beautifully
thank you thank you explain to mum was
in the stuffing please the stuffing has
mushrooms lemon thyme tarragon and
spinach favorite apartment or Ginger I
really enjoy doing the stuffing it's not
as hard as it looks Bon Appetit everyone
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the App Store good luck